hello welcome to this video playing ska
show or something like that okay let's
go back to to this ok you try to play in
somewhat interesting opening and they
come up with with a London system ok so
can I take on between now you very okay
come on let's take that that looks at
least a little bit more interesting than
usual starts with the London system and
then gives gives away material ok um and
qiyam 95 looked a little bit annoying I
have to be of course cautious with the
Queen don't want to get it wrapped
how much is one pawn down yes one porn
yeah that makes sense them getting stuff
out quickly and I want to catch up here
and try to Castle short now c5 is also
pawn that I might be able to take
Rukia one couldn't be true hmm I can you
know take on c6 Bishop takes Bishop b5
no that's not working that's not working
it would be one move in any is this a
move on lord I have queen a three
bishops in 593 I don't I don't think he
can't wrap my queen
aha for the other other look there if I
Teague on c4 is still playing no I have
Quincy to actually I always have Quincy
too okay okay okay okay and then go back
there so i can i can actually cancel the
only takes tags I always have quickly
too well okay okay so that that game was
far more interesting that it not was it
is far more interesting than it seemed
to be at the at the very beginning okay
so what is he going at going for Roxy 1a
checking on c5 so night 95 Roxy 194 EF
Queen f5 should be three wow wow wow wow
alone should be five
93 I Bishop d3 outside okay let's do
this I pull three it's kind of a bug
right here for that for those pawns
we should be three queen age five I
guess you can take age seven then I
wonder is there something better
probably not let's do this
yeah well no choice they don't think
that works check anyway so this this one
should that work I don't get it check I
have Queen at five I mean
I'm a rock up here a complete full rook
so it wants to go with them let's do
this first white resins who I mean okay
I really had to take those pawns and I
don't think it's objectively good and
provide but it's very very tricky of
course he has some kind of compensation
this this the engine wants to go castles
and gives about equal position at White
has compensation that sets totally clear
I just wonder how much it is canceled is
no gay one now we cancel and Bishop
takes engine wants to cheek now on c6
and gives widen advantage okay so
probably Bishop c5 wasn't good that it's
very risky anyway this is what the
computer wants to do now this moves the
point is that this is this is a queen
trap a 97 takes takes and now Knight to
g4 yeah I castle has Bishop t6 and I
it's very dangerous very very dangerous
and there and good for him Jim board
whatever
I had to grab the pawns didn't really
see an alternative like here I Bishop f4
is an interesting and just take p7 yeah
that this is often overlooked those kind
of I mean simple is the wrong word but
solutions that once you see them look
relatively simple what gets the pawn
back it has a very active position
that's definitely okay for him this this
and now Bishop d3 is winning and not
this one okay so i should take with the
e porn then Bishop d3 mmm I had some
doubts there and this this TM and this
is the problem yeah so we had to win he
had a win sorry yeah and he took night
to eat it what he could have done I
thought you had do this this is the
moves I expected if I take with the King
chat end this is very that looks very
dangerous yeah like doing this I would
have taken with the Queen and then who
take that this just looks entirely
unclear I mean he has some attack but I
have two pawns they are connected Paso's
engines has slight advantage from black
butts well anything can happen here yeah
this is just not working yeah okay
that's the typical thing I had this
video hmm like about two weeks ago about
the Greek gift sacrifice and if black or
the defender at the end can cover the
mating square on age seven it's really
almost never working ha thanks for
watching